the European Union and its member states
are the biggest contributors to the
functioning of the United Nations we
have an important role also via our
member states of course in the Security
Council and in the General Assembly but
for the third time I can speak on behalf
of the european union in the General
Assembly exposing also what our views
are not only as an institution in
Brussels but speaking on behalf of the
28 member states and of course this is a
voice that will be heard and Israel
today we are in a new situation the
European Union welcomes the diplomatic
opening created in order to control and
destroy Syria's chemical weapons
there is no solution for the Syrian
crisis than a political solution there
is no military solution for it and a
political solution always needed the
framework of the United Nations and
those who are not convinced they are
rediscovering the importance of
disorganization
mitted a billion dollars Ruth the Geneva
process forward
I have the meeting now with Ukraine
about the association agreement and the
deep and comprehensive free trade
agreement we will sign it will be
hopefully side in Vilnius some
benchmarks have to be met but there is a
clear determination from our side
European Union and I understood also
from the Ukrainian side to go ahead and
finally to sign cause all the criteria
as I have to be met okay that's two
Victor's Africa is important for the
European for historical reasons also for
reasons simply of neighborhood and vice
versa the European Union is very
important for Africa because we are our
main commercial partner we are providing
the biggest amount of development aid we
organize next year and EU Africa summit
hopefully with all the heads of state of
government of all African countries so
for us it is a key region in the world
very close to us a very close
geographically a very close historically
vives of Europe
yep
Giselle
it was really the first time that we met
the new president of iran and we told
him that we appreciated to new tone the
new language used by him and members of
his government but in order to rebuild
trust and Trust was lacking the last
years in the relations between Iran and
the rest of the world in order to
rebuild trust we also need concrete
steps deeds confidence is built on
something very very concrete and the new
president raised expectations
from the first permanent president of
the european council
and its partner
of course I come from a country where
compromise is our second nature
exist
you